a
[Música]
ah
españa es el país de la unión europea
con la tasa más alta de desempleo
juvenil lo que implica a los menores de
25 años es una información que hemos
conocido recientemente por un informe
del eurostat en relación a la situación
de este mes de julio de 2020 y es que si
la media europea de desempleo juvenil se
sitúa alrededor del 17 por ciento en el
caso de españa- sube por encima del 40%
además españa también es el tercer país
donde más ha crecido esta tasa respecto
al año anterior solamente por detrás de
lituania y de suecia eso sí cabe
destacar que no tenemos los datos de
países como grecia que en el mes de mayo
ocupaba el segundo lugar en este ranking
pero es que además españa también
encabeza la lista de desempleo total de
la unión europea pero es que por otro
lado a la crítica situación económica
actual hay que añadirle que las personas
que se integraban ya en el mercado de
trabajo desde hace una década lo hacían
de una forma bastante precaria e
inestable después del estallido de la
crisis de 2008
[Música]
según datos del instituto nacional de
estadísticas 1 de cada 4 jóvenes en
portugal entre 15 y 24 años está sin
empleo la situación se ha agravado por
causa de la pandemia y el cierre del mes
de julio la tasa se ubicó en 26.3 por
ciento aumento con respecto a junio que
se ubicaba en 25 puntos 6% y esto
representaba más de 81 mil jóvenes fuera
del mercado laboral
portugal está muy por encima de la media
de la tasa de la zona euro que se ubicó
en 17.3 por ciento y de la unión europea
que se ubicó en 17% si hablamos de
índices de desempleo en general al
cierre del mes de julio las proyecciones
es de 8.1 por ciento de desempleo entre
junio y julio se habrían perdido más de
39 mil puestos de trabajo y estarían
afectados más de 400.000 personas estas
son cifras que no se veían en portugal
desde hace aproximadamente tres años el
presidente se ha pronunciado al respecto
y asegura que ésta no es más que la
punta de la jce verde una gran crisis
económica que no ha tenido peores
resultados gracias a las medidas que se
han adoptado como por ejemplo la
denominada
leyó simplificada y algunas ayudas que
ha hecho el gobierno
[Música]
el desempleo juvenil no ha parado de
aumentar en los últimos meses en la
unión europea especialmente a causa de
la crisis derivada por el coronavirus
según las últimas estadísticas en julio
de 2020 casi 3 millones de jóvenes
menores de 25 años estaban desempleados
en la unión europea esto es una tasa del
17% de desempleo juvenil españa grecia e
italia son los países que lideran este
ranking de hecho es una tendencia que ya
se produjo hace 10 años en que estos
mismos países durante la anterior crisis
económica también tenían el mayor número
de desempleados juveniles de hecho ahora
con la crisis del coronavirus han vuelto
a salir estas flaquezas de los países
con mayor tasa de desempleo juvenil
porque son países que dependen mucho del
turismo un sector que además ha estado
gravemente afectado por la crisis de el
coronavirus también tienen una alta tasa
de abandono escolar y un gran número de
jóvenes que ni estudian ni trabajan
[Música]